hello everyone thank you very much for
being here with me today at ndc sydney
i'm really looking forward to presenting
to you from horror story to fairy tale
writing code that people want to read
i am happy to take questions throughout
the presentation feel free to either
unmute yourself and
chime in or to leave comments in the
room 4 channel in slack i'll be
monitoring that as well if you have any
questions or comments throughout the
session and there are a few places that
i'll be looking for interaction so
please feel free to interrupt at any
point and i look forward to talking with
you
so
when we are building software
we have some goals some design goals
and i'm happy to listen to any goals
that you have when you're writing
software there's a few things that i've
come up with
some implicit goals that we have
first one i came up with is that the
program does what it is supposed to do
right that's an important goal when
we're building software and it's
something that we always have but don't
necessarily write down anywhere it's
kind of an implied thing are there other
implied design goals you can think of
that we have when we are building and
designing software
perhaps there's no bugs
perhaps there are no security
vulnerabilities and feel free to type
them into slack or just chime in
the software should be easy to use right
that's a goal we commonly have
when we're building software
and another one that is often a goal but
not something that's necessarily
codified is that the code should be easy
to modify as the requirements change we
want to be able to
develop the continue to develop on the
software over time we want it to be able
to grow and adapt and change
and there's a lot of things that we do
to kind of build this into our processes
but we don't always identify this as a
stated clearly defined goal of our
projects but it's often there in the
background
so with these goals in mind these
implicit goals in mind let's talk about
the active writing software
so where do you spend your time as a
developer
what are things that you spend time on
some of the activities that you do
may include
typing code
actually physically entering code into
the system
what are some other things you do you
may
do brainstorming or spend time problem
solving
working things out in your head or on a
whiteboard or whatever that may look
like one of the top answers i get to
this question is of course
meetings we spend a lot of time
interacting in whether it's a virtual
meeting or an in-person meeting we spend
a lot of time talking with each other
hashing things out
uh one type of thing that we do is
testing we write unit tests maybe we do
manual testing
integration tests whatever type of
testing we're doing we do a lot of it
and sometimes we spend more time
writing code for tests than we spend
writing the code that we're testing
documentation right not all the writing
we do is code
some of the code the writing we do is
just documentation or plain english
whether it's technical documentation or
user documentation that's another thing
we may do in part of our role as a
software developer
so
all of these things have something in
common and that is we spend a lot of
time reading code we have to understand
the could that has been written whether
it was written by us or someone else
so we spend a lot of time reading code
in fact from the book clean code
the ratio of time spent reading versus
writing is well over ten to one we are
constantly reading old code as part of
the effort to write new code therefore
making code easier to read
makes it easier to write
another quote this is a
known as eagleson's law it's
unattributed
any code of your own that you haven't
looked at for six or more months might
as well have been written by somebody
else
and i've actually seen a number of
people claim that that's probably as
short as
eight or ten weeks
when we put something out of our head
for just a few weeks
when we come back to it
we've got to pick it back up again it's
no longer in our working memory it's no
longer ready
we've got to go back through the effort
of
figuring it out
therefore it might as well be written by
somebody else
another quote that i love about this
concept of reading code
from martin fowler any tool can write
good can write code that a computer can
understand but good programmers write
code that humans can understand and this
this brings me
to an important concept about code
and when we think about the activities
that we do
as programmers in fact
let's go back to that list really
quickly
only one of these involves writing code
but all of them involve reading code
right and because of this
code perhaps
doesn't exist to tell the computer what
to do that is not its primary function
its primary function is perhaps to serve
as documentation and communication to
other developers
yes it needs to do what we set out for
it to do but it spends most of its time
most of the life
of the code we write is spent as
communication to people
not necessarily to the machine
it's an important perspective for us to
have when we think about how we're going
to write code
so a quick introduction of myself i have
been working as a software developer for
more than 20 years
and i have worked for a number of
different startups and companies i have
definitely written some horror story
code in the past
and we're going to look a little bit at
some horror story code
look at
code that was written just for the
machine
and then look at ways that we can
process this
so here is a code example of bad code
that i pulled from the daily wtf which
is a great fail blog website for
developers
and i challenge you to tell me
in two minutes what this does
it's very interesting to look at
what is it doing it let's look at the
first line you are converting
a fixed time string to a date time
object and then back to a string
and then back to a date time object and
then back to a string wait that's no
except that's datetime.now so now we
have the current time as a string and
this other thing is a string and we're
doing all this manipulation and this
code the way it is written
takes time to figure out and when we get
all the way down to the bottom we're
saying if x is greater than 10. wait
hold up where does x come from
if we look that it's on a split as a
split of a result we're subtracting the
two dates
we're splitting them my guess is
that's returning true if there's
10 or more day or there's more than 10
days between today and the other date
but i'm not 100 sure i'd have to really
dig into that
it's not immediately obvious
the the naming of the variables does not
help us there are no comments to help us
there is an assumption that we're going
to be able to understand this there's no
context of why we're doing it
right
at the end of the day we're bringing in
we're bringing in dates and returning a
boolean true or false
so one thing that we can do to make code
easier to read is potentially to have
more descriptive variable names so let's
look at this example
very long variable names
inventory integration direction dot do
the same change in shop
calling a function do the same changes
shop
what does that mean
do the same change in shop did the same
changes what same as what we use the
word like same it indicates that we are
comparing something that we're doing
something in relation to another thing
but there's no other thing here
for us to compare with the same is what
get changed data from inventory okay so
the data's changed it's changed based
upon a sync date but then what am i
doing with it the only verb here is do
and so maybe maybe if i was working on
this software and i had all the context
of this piece of software in my head
this might possibly make sense to me but
it's certainly not going to make sense
to a brand new developer starting on
this project they're going to have no
idea what this means
so even though we have used long
variable names descriptive variable
names all these things then it doesn't
help because the specific language we've
used is not helpful so now instead of
something that is short and confusing we
have something that is verbose
and confusing and that's not helpful
last example
another example from the daily wtf
what does this do
does it return true or false at the
bottom if everything's successful
it takes this time to process this and
there's a few reasons why
first we're starting by setting
something to false that we're or
equaling it to something else which
means the previous value or the next
value
and then
but we're ordering it to the negation of
the return of another thing
update file sir template
presumably that might return true if
it's successful
and then at the bottom we're negating
that result
but the name of the variable is also a
not so here's what's going on we have
lots and lots of negations we have one
two three four what do we have ten
negations in here 12 negations
negations are actually really hard to
read
negatives take time because we always
kind of in our head convert those
negatives to positives in order to
understand the thing that's actually
happening
and so when we write code like this sure
this may be really elegant it may work
really really well but it takes time to
process and understand okay is this
going to return true or false at the end
when it's successful
so there are ways that we can write code
to make this easier to read without
necessarily making any longer more
verbose
so we need to think about those things
when we're looking at code and
understand that the more straightforward
the code is the easier it is going to be
to read
so why do we care
i've shown you some examples of bad code
potentially
but
is it really that big of a deal like if
i ran out of that code i would be able
to figure out what it did i'd be able to
make my changes i'd be able to move
along my life so why do i care
about writing more readable code
and one of those reasons is that there
is confusion
code is a form of communication
when there's confusion in our
communication it's hard to know what's
going on i'm going to read a quick quote
from spacex
excessive use of made-up acronyms is a
significant impediment to communication
and keeping communication good as we
grow is incredibly important
individually a few acronyms here or
there may not seem so bad but if a
thousand people are making these up over
time the result will be a huge glossary
that we have to issue to new employees
no one can actually remember all these
acronyms and people don't want to seem
dumb in a meeting so they just sit there
in ignorance and this is particularly
tough on new employees
so this is a great example of why
acronyms may be bad or harmful because
they don't necessarily mean anything to
us until we've learned this essentially
learned a brand new language
but this applies actually to anything
where the language that we're using
isn't going to be immediately obvious to
somebody that is new to the team or the
project
whether it's an acronym or not
so anytime we have
are using communication in a way that is
confusing to newcomers
we have created a problem in our
organization that we're going to
overcome one reason that is a problem
is because we are always onboarding
people to our teams
even small teams even well established
teams we tend to on board people fairly
regularly that might be because
many developers switch jobs every two
years two to four years
it could be because we're hiring outside
contractors to expand our resources to
to work on specific parts of our
projects it could be because our teams
are growing
whatever the reason
anytime we bring somebody new onto our
team if we have introduced confusion it
is harder for them to get up and running
harder for them to be able to contribute
value to our project that looks bad on
them
but it's also bad for us because now
those of us that are still there are
happen to work extra hard to make up
that difference
another reason that this is important is
for inclusivity
not
everybody has the exact same background
as a developer
some developers come from computer
science degrees they have a master's in
computer science they may be worked at
google microsoft or facebook and that is
their background we may have other
developers that
they graduated high school went to a
coding academy and started coding and
both of those backgrounds are perfectly
valid
but
that means you have a different
common language to use when you're
working on things and it means that
different people have different access
to or different have gone through
different educational paths when
learning to code and therefore the way
we write our code
is going to be more
easily understood
by some developers than others
so we need to think about this are we
inadvertently
creating barriers to entry
for future developers based upon the way
we build our code when we think about
our code s communication to future
developers
it's very important
accessibility
clean code
semantic code especially things that are
ui related like html is a very important
part of it an accessibility
implementation
but it's also important to remember
that the developers you work with may
also
have need for accessibility tools
maybe your the developers you are
working with need to be able to
customize their ide with different
colors
because they have color deficiency they
don't see colors the same way you do
they may have other disabilities that
make it harder for them to do certain
things than others and if we have
written code in a way that is not easily
approached through accessibility tools
we've made it harder for those people to
work on our projects and that is a huge
problem
we don't want to do that
another reason to write clean
approachable easily understood easy to
read code is that it's easier to avoid
bugs
the more straightforward our code is the
easier it is to identify bugs to avoid
them in the first place and often this
makes the code more
testable again when it's easy to write
tests when it's easy when accessibility
is easy automation is easier consistency
helps us build automation and maybe save
ourselves time through document
conversion code generation text parsing
linting all these types of things these
are all examples of automation that help
us as developers to make our lives
easier
another thing that factors into code is
communication is going to be naming
it's just one small aspect of code
readability
but it is a fairly important one and
it's a fairly challenging one in fact
this quote this is an old quote from
phil clark colton
was working on netscape navigator at the
time i believe there are only two hard
things in computer science cash
invalidation a known hard problem
and naming things
so
coming up with good meaningful names
phil was saying is just as hard
as some of the hardest problems in
computer science
it is a challenge
but it is a challenge that is worth our
time and effort in just the same way
that solving the hard problems are
when we talk about names what are things
that make naming or word choice
good or bad how do we
kind of decide
what this is
one of the challenges that comes up is
ambiguity and ambiguity of course refers
to any word or phrase for which a single
cohesive concept cannot be identified at
least without some additional context so
using an example in
spoken english what if i say there there
or there
what do i mean well there's three
different words that i could mean when i
say that
what about two
two or two
three more possible things that i could
mean they all have slightly different
meanings very different meanings in fact
and so we don't know when i say 2
without the rest of the sentence around
it what do i mean
so this is an example of ambiguity and
we have written ambiguities as well
there are plenty of examples in english
for example that
when you write something it may look the
same way but then sound different but it
means two different things and we need
additional context to understand what
we're talking about
when i say free
what do i mean
what about when i say software is free
do i mean
free isn't popcorn
or do i mean free as in free to use
however i want free is in freedom
or free isn't free of cost
there are always different nuances to
the words and if that nuance matters if
that difference in understanding matters
then we need to provide enough context
to allow the reader to make the right
decision because this is ambiguous
ambiguity comes up a lot in acronyms and
abbreviations but also acronyms and
abbreviations are not always necessarily
universally understood
so here are a few acronyms abbreviations
and initialisms that i've run across as
a software developer that people don't
necessarily agree on
in my humble opinion or in my honest
opinion i've seen people legitimately
get angry with each other for not
agreeing on this which is
it's close enough right we understand in
my humble or honest opinion but
there's no consensus on which one it
actually is
a content management system i once
worked
on a content management system named cms
for
centers for medicare and medicaid
services here in the u.s also cms
so i had cms with for cms with cms
cms was flying all over the place nobody
had any idea we were talking about it
was great
all types of different examples
where we may or may not know exactly
what we mean when we see this out of
context
ram could be
memory
it could be an animal
do we have the context is it all
uppercases at mixedcase my personal
favorite though is s t
this could mean stanza but it can also
mean street
straight
saint
uh star trek
the wikipedia page the disambiguation
page for st
has i think 34 entries for st and half
of them are related to addresses
which means that even knowing that st is
being used in the context of an address
doesn't tell me enough to know for sure
what word it is that it's being
substituted for
so acronyms and abbreviations can be
really harmful for actually
communicating the full intent of what
we're saying
but enough
about the horror story let's get into
the fairy tale i've talked about
ambiguity i've shown examples of code
that is hard to read i've hopefully
explained
why
this is important
now let's look at some ways that we can
approach
solving these problems and the first
thing we need to be able to do
is assess whether or not the code we're
writing is easy to read or not
how do i know
how do i know if this is good or bad
so one
thing we can look at is semantics so
semantics is the branch of linguistics
and logic
concerned with meaning
in code this refers to choosing the
right words and structures to convey
that intended meaning
so for example
if i use process
user that is
not very semantically meaningful it just
tells me that i'm doing something could
just as easily say do stuff
doesn't mean anything but login user
login means something it's telling me
what's happening with that user
in html for example if i use a div tag
it doesn't give me any context or or
meaning related to what's going to be
contained by that tag but if i use a nav
tag now i know that this is wrapping
navigation
and this is a really important that we
use this correctly because this is a
perfect example of accessibility in
action by making the right choice
we help assistive technologies
communicate more effectively to the user
what's going on
if we choose the div instead we're not
providing enough context or meaning for
somebody to understand what's actually
happening here
so that additional semantic is really
important so
one lens we can use to review our code
is
semantics another
way to review our our meaning is the
vocabulary so words that are used are
only particularly meaningful if they
exist within the vocabulary of those who
are reading them in the future
okay
so if you go back and you read something
that was written 100 years ago
you're going to have a lot harder time
understanding it than if you read
something that was read yesterday why
because language changes over time
and that's normal but we still need to
be really careful that we don't
add additional complexity where it
doesn't need to be so let's look at some
vocabulary examples and these are
examples of of ambiguity as well
reciprocal what does reciprocal mean
in mathematics
it means
it can mean the inverse it can mean the
opposite
in relationships it could mean
reciprocity if i do something for you
you disappoint for something for me but
those meanings
depend upon us sharing the same frame of
reference if we both know that we're
having a conversation about mathematics
that's fine we know what reciprocal
means in that situation but
if we know we're talking about
relationships then we know what we're
meaning but if we don't know what the
context is then reciprocal may be
confusing another one great example is
re
if i say re
what do i mean
do you know is there enough information
what's the context are we talking about
mathematics
where it's a point with a line that
extends in one direction or we're
talking about zoology
where it is an animal that kind of flows
swims through the ocean or perhaps i'm
talking about a ray of sunlight
so it's important that
if we share a common specific vocabulary
if i know for example that i'm talking
about mathematics then i can use these
words with confidence knowing that
future readers are going to understand
this context but if the context itself
is ambiguous then i need to provide that
additional context so that they
understand
what that how to process that word
in the place that i've used it
one of the things that i've run into in
software is that sometimes different
industries
use similar words to mean slightly
different things or even sometimes very
different things insurance and banking
for example may have they use a lot of
the same financial terms but they may
define them in subtly different ways and
that those subtle differences are
extremely important when we're building
software we have to be perfectly precise
so it's important that we are
clear in exactly what the definition of
those terms is within the context of our
projects
failing to follow the vocabulary of your
industry can also be very expensive one
company that i worked for was actually
an insurance company
insurance at least in the us has very
clearly defines terminology as an
industry standard there are
specific definitions of things that are
useful for building integrations between
organizations well the company i was
working for didn't really do that very
well
so instead of converting their platforms
to use this common language
they built custom integrations to every
single product service and tool that
they needed to integrate with
because they weren't doing things the
way everybody else was
that
choice to have their own vocabulary
became very expensive over time
another thing to to use to
kind of determine if our what we're
writing is clear or not is to look at
intent
can i look at
this code can i read it and understand
the intent of the author do i understand
when i should use the same bit of code
in the things that i write
so
a function name such as convert time
i don't necessarily know when i might
want to call that to convert time what
what's the context here when
do i use this why is it being used here
in the code i don't know for sure
but if i instead
indicate the intent and the name of the
function
local to utc for example
i understand that i am converting
that date from a local time zone to a
utc time zone now i understand
what it's doing and when i would use it
another example check username we'll
check it for what am i checking checking
to see if it's already taken if i'm
checking to see if it's logged in i'm
checking to see what am i checking
is it valid uh
is it am i checking it against the dirty
words list what am i doing with this
thing
so if i instead provide that intent and
the name is username available
now i can read that code and immediately
understand
why it's being used here and when i
might also want to use it
disambiguation so i spoke earlier about
ambiguity and ambiguity is a big part of
confusion and language so let's look at
how to disambiguate things so
for example execute could mean a few
different things run a process or kill
something so maybe we should use run or
kill
instead
to be really clear about what we meant
light
does this mean bright or
not heavy not dark or not heavy right
just i could use bright
i could use i don't know
light is in weight i can use a weight
variable to indicate the the the
heaviness of something i can use
heaviness as a rating so a lot of
different things that i can do to make
it clear the context
of
what i mean when i use the word light
uh ephemeral use one thing that happens
a lot ephemeral so sorry ephemeral means
temporary or for a limited time and a
lot of the code that we write is
temporary
it's a fundamental component of agile
development which many of us use agile
methodologies right and
we know that the code we write is going
to be their temporary we have this habit
sometimes the software developers to for
example implement a quick fix
that we're going to come back and fix
later and then it sticks around for a
really really long time
i'm sure that i've run into this a lot
i'm sure you have too
and then in some environments like in in
a corporate environment you may end up
with stuff that sticks around for a
really really long time that was
intended to be temporary in a startup
environment sometimes you have the
opposite you write things thinking it's
going to be there forever and
then you discover you have to rewrite it
again three months later whatever
point is that we need to be really
cautious about the longevity of the
thing we're writing and how long
the communication will be valid for
here's an example silly example from
xkcd
this
function
is valid exactly once
the first time we call it it's a random
number
the second time we call it it is not
this is a
ridiculously extreme example of
ephemeral code in that it is useful
exactly once
but it illustrates the point right we
need to make sure that when we implement
something we can certainly ut has
utility beyond the first time we call it
the first time we use it
here's another example this is a visual
example uh using css and web design
you have been working on the user
interface for a website their marketing
team gave you the branding colors
here is what you put together with those
colors
fast forward a few months and they tell
you hey we really want to change the
color palette to this here
you're like fine no big deal i'll go in
and plug in a few variables or
update the thing we're done
easy peasy
but there's a problem
that's the problem
so we have
a dot orange class represent orange but
we have a dot blue class represent
yellow and a dot green class to
represent purple what in the world
happened
well what happened is that when we
originally set up these color palettes
blue did represent blue and green did
represent green
and then we used those class names all
over the html
to
specify things what colors we wanted
things to be and then when the time came
to make that change
it was really really easy to change the
hex code definition in the one place on
that css class but it was
prohibitive
to change the name of the class
everywhere is being used so we didn't
bother
and this is something that i see a lot
and the the solution here is of course
that maybe we should have had use names
like primary color secondary color
tertiary color and then we can use those
everywhere freely without giving an
indication that it's going to be blue
necessarily
another quick css example
and this is a situation where when we
want to refactor something we have to be
really careful about how it's being used
and we need to make sure that we write
code in a way that it can be refactored
like i said at the beginning of the talk
one of the implicit design goals of most
software is that it's easy to modify
over time
right so here's an example another
example i've seen a lot we have a css
class called write
and in this particular implementation it
has been implemented as text to line
write
and one interesting thing i've seen in
css frameworks over time over the years
i've seen
most of the css frameworks have some
class like this implemented right but 50
of them implement it like this and the
other 50 implemented as float right
so just because i see this doesn't
necessarily mean i know how it's going
to be used but
let's continue
so
i have these numeric columns and i want
them to be right justified because
that's how i want to present numbers and
i use my class right because it does
what i want it to do and i'm reusing
code and so i'm following the
rules of code reuse and i'm this is
fantastic and then later on i have this
other numeric value that i want uh right
justified it's the the counter for how
many characters have been typed into a
comment field
and everything's fine but then there's a
requirement to change the way that
counter looks
so i implement the change right there in
the class because it's there and now it
looks like this and i have no problems
it looks good it gets passed it gets
merged
and then somebody starts complaining hey
why do my
columns of tabular data look bad
they're not supposed to look like this
well i didn't see that because i didn't
test every single
place in the application when i made
that little css change and now i have a
problem i could have avoided this
problem very easily by
using this more specific
semantically meaningful name numeric
column
and now if i need to change anything
else about numeric columns i can do that
right here and then this other thing
this could have been a character counter
and then i could have changed it over
time and the lesson here
is that just because
a function a class
has the exact same implementation has
the exact same
text the same bit of code inside of it
does not mean that it is the same code
so when we started we had this class of
right that used text to line write
and we reused it to avoid typing text to
line right a second time but that was a
mistake that wasn't a good example of
code reuse because
we were using it for completely
different contexts completely different
scenarios completely different purposes
and that means that when the
the meaning diverged because it really
they meant different things in the first
place as that could starts to diverge
now we have to do work to separate those
meanings
instead of continuing to use that same
thing we can't reuse that so it's we
need to be careful when we're trying to
reuse code that we don't inadvertently
reuse code that has a very different
purpose and will have a very different
future trajectory
so
one of the rules that i use in writing
code is the rule of three
if i have to use something three times
before i try to find a way to reuse it
and it has to have the exact same
purpose has this have the same meaning
the same intent if it doesn't share an
intent
i don't care if the code is the same i'm
not going to give it the same name i'm
not going to call the same function i'm
going to create a duplicate with a
different name with its own intent
meaning
so here's an example of refactoring
potentially gone poorly so what can
happen when we we come up with rules for
what good clean codes should look like
and we implement them in a linter and we
prevent people from committing to the
repository if the rules aren't followed
what we end up with maybe is a situation
where
let's say that this was a 1200 line
function
and we implemented this rule where a
function can be no longer than 500 lines
and that sounds great because we know
that shorter functions are easier to
read but then somebody comes in here
and they're like well
i'm in a hurry because we always are
right
i'm going to
break this into three separate functions
just call them in order and move on with
my life
and i haven't made anything easier to
read i haven't made anything easier to
understand i've actually added a whole
new layer of misdirection
to this function just to satisfy a rule
so i need to be really careful in
avoiding
a situation where we're encouraging
battery factors just to follow rules
so
one thing that can sometimes come up and
bite us when writing code is
spelling
and
i this is a this is a tough one because
i don't ever want to make fun of
somebody or pick on somebody for
spelling
it's it's harder for some people than
others and it's not
we don't all speak the same language
natively
okay and so
this is a sticky point but the challenge
here is that when we're trying to modify
our refactor code over time
when we are trying to find for example
every place that expiration is used so
we can make a code change related to
that
if there are misspellings such as the
ones in this example
that's very hard to do
because most of our tools do not do a
very good job of providing alternate
spellings
of the code we're searching for
which means if there is a typo we simply
won't find it
just the same as typos though if we use
abbreviations sometimes and use the full
word and other times
those are two different things i'm going
to have to search for now to find it and
i have to know that that is a search i
need to perform
so
trying to refactor code in the future
when we are inconsistent with how we
write things can be really challenging
and
one thing you can use as an indication
if your code being
fairy tale code is that as you start to
build things it's the implementation
strategies are fairly straightforward
if they're not if you find yourself
writing really convoluted code or
jumping through a lot of hoops in your
code that are really hard to follow a
lot of times that's actually a sign of a
poor architecture maybe you need a
different data model maybe you need a
different algorithm maybe you need a
different structure to your code to make
it easier to share the things you need
to share or to process the data the way
you need to process it
so
i like to look at confusing code not
just as a hey this is bad code it needs
to be fixed but maybe there's actually
an under this is a symptom of an
underlying problem that we need to
address instead
and here's an example of this so
when we see chaos and confusion in our
code it may be a sign of an underlying
problem in this particular case the
first thing we notice right away we have
a string one an s1 and s2 variable that
are both strings and they're being
reassigned to each other repeatedly well
it's pretty easy for us to look at that
and realize that that could have just
been one variable for starters
all the way down in fact we didn't even
necessarily need the variable because
looking at that it's very obvious that
we could have just chained dot replaces
together in a line so we didn't even
need the variables in the first place so
we've added complexity here
and these variable names s1 and s2 first
of all they're not descriptive
and second of all
they're their the way they're being used
is redundant so we can look at this and
immediately say okay the person that
wrote this
may not fully understand how that
replace method works maybe they don't
understand how the string assignments
work maybe
something else but it's something it's
worth asking that question at that point
how can we simplify this and the really
interesting thing is that what's really
dangerous here is if you look at that we
have an sw dot right s2 at the bottom
if we look at that particular line of
code near the bottom
if i were to use s1 instead of s2 there
it might not work so if i add an
additional dot replace
to the string of that replaces it may
not get picked up correctly maybe that
that last change doesn't get written
because now it's assigned to the other
variable and that can be a source of
bugs
so
using these redundant variable names
actually can easily make this code hard
to fix hard to improve or add on to can
introduce
pretty subtle bugs in the future
just because we use the variable name we
didn't need to
so
getting to this point
we want fairy tale code we've talked
about some strategies for
doing that but
let's make this more concrete more
applicable i'm going to give you a
checklist for some things that i do
to help me ensure that i am producing
good code that is easy
for other developers to read and to be
blunt the person that probably benefits
from this the most is future me
when i write code that's easy to read
when i come back to it later i benefit
from that
so the first thing to consider is your
audience
the very next person to touch this code
is most likely a developer who did not
have the requirements or conversations
you just had
in their head maybe they didn't have
those conversations at all they
certainly don't have that context in
their head right now so if you went off
and had a few conversations with people
that you sat down and you wrote this
code
they don't have all that context when
they come back and look at it later and
this again this could be future you
so anything that was confusing or
difficult or required external
conversations required you to look up
documentation in order to figure out how
to write this
that should be passed along to the next
developer with as much context as
possible
so again
the future audience does not have access
to all your external contents but they
are busy and distracted we always are
when we're writing software a lot of
times we're in a hurry
we have a long list of things we're
trying to do
and we're trying to do it quickly and
easily
so let's make this as easy for us to do
as possible
we need to use specific language
names for example should be specific and
written in the common language of your
problem domain do you work for an
insurance company great use that common
language do you work for a dentist
perfect use that terminology
you can in general assume a certain
level of technology
specific language as well
but if you're going to deviate too far
out of your core industry then it's
really important that you clarify that
so when we talk about specific names
provide context and clues to what
something means so in this particular
example tax
well what do i mean when i say tax
there's so many different types of taxes
and the tax is that tax a number is that
a specific amount of currency
or is it a rate in other words a
percentage that i have to multiply some
other value to find the actual tax
amount
i don't know from looking at just the
word tax
so i can provide that additional context
i can use be more specific so sales tax
rate tells me that this is a
going to help me calculate the sales tax
and i'm in order to do that i'm going to
multiply this by the total value and
produce the actual sales tax amount
i know that just from looking at that
variable name
item order quantity it's not just qty
it's the quantity of items in an order
perfect i know i have contacts now i
understand what that means
actions
function and method names should include
a verb
names like this are very bad because
they don't tell us what we're actually
doing we know that functions are actions
we know an action is being performed so
i know that an action is being performed
to the sales tax or an action is being
performed by the order quantity but i
don't know what that action is
that means that when i see this in code
i have to drill into that function and
read the func the code related to that
function implementation to actually
understand what's going on
or i could provide a more appropriate
name which includes the verb the action
being performed
so that i have that context just from
looking at the call without having to
actually look at the implementation of
the function itself
so calculate sales tax tells me that i'm
calculating sales tax and presumably by
the variables that i pass in now i'll
understand how that calculation is being
performed
fetch order quantity that tells me i'm
retrieving something probably from a
database or other data store
use full words use abbreviations
sparingly
and
when you use abbreviations there should
be no confusion as what it means
stats
probably actually an okay one
but whatever you choose be consistent if
you're going to use a specific
abbreviation always use that
abbreviation don't use the abbreviation
sometimes with the full word sometimes
don't
don't create creative misspellings of
existing words so this is something i've
seen in java a lot the word class is a
reserved word it's a reserved word in
almost every program languages i've ever
used
what i see in a lot of libraries then is
that people will come up with creative
ways to
come up with a way to spell this
that is not a reserved word so c-l-a-z-z
or klass
class and class
and realistically there's no point in
that it could just easily be class name
right or class instance if you're
passing an object or perhaps it could be
the css class or the the css class names
if it's a array of multiple things it
could be classes there's so many ways
that we could do this that were
meaningful without creating a
misspelling
and
it's really important that we use full
words as much as possible so that
everybody automatically knows how to
search for them
when we sometimes use abbreviations and
sometimes don't we create this kind of
guess method to finding
bits of code that we need when we're
trying to solve a problem
because a lot of times what happens at
least in my experience when i get a
story to work on some code and it's
related to a specific concept one of the
first things i'm going to do is search
through the code base for the keyword
related to that concept and see what's
out there
and if we've not used full words i'm not
going to get results
related to that spelling
most editors support spell checks at
this point in time i use vs code i do
use a spell check in there
spell check is a great resource to just
help make sure that we have made our
code easy to search
and that it is
one reason that spelling matters also as
well as full words is that if we are
working with somebody that uses a screen
reader to understand the code or other
assistive technology it will actually
make sense instead of just being an
amalgamation of letters that have to get
spelled out
and spelling sometimes
can be kind of
interesting
so
referrer
actually has two r's but in the original
http specification it had just one r in
the specification and therefore we've
ended up with
this misspelling being implemented in
basically every single web browser and
uh web server ever
because it made it all the way into the
specification like that and that just it
creates challenge for for people to who
are trying to work with that so we need
to make sure and that create versus
create is another one that's in the c
library
use the full word correctly spelled and
we will save ourselves headache down the
road
comments this is a big one right
comments are really important one of the
things that i've said a few times is
that we need to provide context comments
are a great way to provide additional
context in our code of what's going on
why we approach something specific way
but we don't want comments like this
i can look at the code and tell you that
it's iterating over a list of items
right so comments should apply to
explain why or how
not what's happening
so for example
here i am calculating the sum of
quantity and price for each item
that's
and then for verification per cr-123
that's not just
repeating the code that's telling me
something valuable and maybe i don't
need that calculate sum of quantity and
price maybe that's totally redundant
because it's obvious in the code but it
might not be if i'm just passing a bunch
of objects into a function
and i don't get to see which properties
are being extracted it might not be
obvious there
so i need to consider carefully how much
comment do i need to be meaningful
without being
too verbose
how comments can be useful when
auto-generating documentation from your
comments
whenever you need to say i had a
conversation with so and so about this
thing and and we we made this decision
because of xyz provide that we decided
to implement this this way
because of this specific factor put that
in a comment
because in the future the next person to
come in there
they will avoid doing a damaging or
harmful refactor without carefully
considering that
reason that you had when you wrote the
code the way you did
one thing that you can use to provide
context as well as comments is name
spacing
business state here in the u.s state
could mean things like california or
florida but it could also mean open
closed operating not operating right we
don't necessarily understand what that
means for a business state so business
dot address dot state tells me that that
state is related to the address of the
business it's a location
total by itself doesn't tell me anything
but order.total does
so
namespacing or or object context is one
way that we can provide the additional
information that we need to understand
what the code is doing take advantage of
that that avoids duplication and
redundancy i don't need to say business
dot address dot address state
or
business dot address dot business
address state that's it's redundant i
don't need that
name spacing is great
and one of the best ways in my
experience to make some of these
improvements in your code and on your
team is to put together a checklist of
specific
things that you as a team want to do
come up with a handful of
guidelines
come up with team agreements and this
can be related to naming this can be
related to just general approach to code
how you're going to do your code reviews
and then work through those checklists
together in the code review
and however you do code reviews
you should definitely have a kind of a
it doesn't be super formal but you
should have a process that you follow
consistently
make this checklist part of your code
reviews and the reason i like to use
code reviews instead of
hard and fast rules and like a linter
for example is
if the linter starts failing
or produces warnings
then that is going to cause a situation
where
you're encouraging your developers to do
things that could be potentially harmful
or problematic just to get the linter to
pass or you may be teaching them to just
kind of ignore warnings because there's
so many warnings that they just started
ignoring them and that's bad as well but
in a code review we can implement
changes in code that would normally fail
everything
and we can slowly as we address the code
work together to make improvements that
we agree on and they don't have to be
hard and fast rules they can we can
decide together that hey
this code
in this situation this rule just doesn't
make sense let's not apply the rule in
this situation and you can agree to that
and maybe you can change your team
agreements accordingly but remember code
reviews are not exist to remind everyone
how smart you are they are not there to
make other people feel bad the purpose
of code reviews is to apply consistency
on your team to apply consistency to
code and it's a great resource for
mentorship but in my team i apply this
as a mentorship not just from senior
developers to junior developers but the
other way around because newer
developers giving you common comments
and feedback on your code are going to
help you produce more readable code
because
they're going to point out right away
the things that are confusing and if
it's confusing to them it's going to be
confusing to other people as well
and it's going to help you write more
approachable code that is easier for new
developers and new people to your team
to pick up and read very easily
so
we want to live of course happily ever
after this is fairy tale code after all
so quick summary code
is a form of communication between
developers that is
how it spends most of its life
communication
including code is communication
should be clear succinct and specific
we want to convey meaning and intent
with the language we use
readable code
in its very existence by making our code
readable we support inclusivity
accessibility
and also the company's bottom line
because we make it easier for new
developers to get up and running we make
it
easier to avoid bugs we make it quicker
and cheaper to make changes and fixes to
the code
so it really does help the bottom line
as well
and the one great way to do this is to
create team agreements together
about how we're going to approach this
code and then support that through
code reviews
so i want to thank you very much for
your time and attention today i'm happy
to answer any questions we have just a
couple minutes
and i will follow up in slack later as
well if you want to hit me up in there
and feel free to follow me on twitter as
well but thank you so much